non-minimalists
i left the us because of the constant
pressures of societal normality
religious views and people always
crossing boundaries that you set as if
it's the joke
or you're wrong my question is how do
you deal with the constant judging or
breaking of boundaries you set without
being almost too aggressive
so jess i think this was a necessary
question here because
brian sort of opted out of i don't know
western culture i i suppose
he and his wife um i know you don't hear
the entire voicemail but
he and his wife are living in china sort
of digital nomads
i'll be honest i don't really know what
that means so maybe you can enlighten
the uh
the uh listenership on what a digital
nomad is
i've heard the term a million times and
i sort of smile and nod like i know what
uh they're talking about
but he the problem he had it sounds to
me he didn't use this word but
tribalism the the the the binary the
you're on team red or team blue team r
team d and there are a hundred different
examples of this team conspiracy or
team uh i don't know round earth or
whatever like
all of these these these teams
and he wanted to opt out of that but i
also think that's sort of part of our
our human nature
so can we talk a bit about boundaries
and
boundaries that maybe you set up during
uh with social media
and uh what what would you tell brian
well i think
um i think one thing that i would tell
brian is i mean
when we're thinking about social media
becoming a distraction i think that what
we're also
not thinking about is the overarching
like value of our life
because when we talk about minimalism
we're always looking for the why
and i feel like when you're deriving a
lot of value from your life those
distractions become less enticing
because you realize what you're
it's pulling you away from so i feel
like really placing emphasis on those
things that
you value so much and and focusing on
what your mission is
in life i think that that's one of the
first things that i would say that he
needs to do if i'm
you know he may have already done that
but like
that will give you the leverage as we
talk about to move forward effectively
so when you do hit a distraction you
know why it's important to walk away
from it
yeah i wish i had more information on
the boundaries that he's talking about
um i'm assuming i'm assuming it's
boundaries with like friends and family
and yeah yeah yeah it sounds to me like
um
just by the way i think you bring up a
great point if you're if you're living
an incredible meaningful life the
these sort of mundane distractions even
though you get that dopamine rush it's
going to seem so
weak in comparison to the strength of
of a of a meaningful life of course that
that does require a lot more
you know cerebration than celebration is
often what i'll say
like we have to we have to we have to
build up the strength of
a of a well-lived life
and constantly pacifying ourselves
or distracting ourselves with the device
is not
uh is not a way to do that in fact
that's how we atrophy
i think in many ways ryan talk about the
boundaries though
yeah he's talking about you know
sometimes it might feel harsh
and guess what it probably does brian
you picked up and moved to china
uh that's to some people that's going to
feel harsh as well
a few things that i would say and and
jess knows i'm going to give this answer
but
you don't have to explain yourself to
anyone and and
as soon as you start to feel like you
you're compelled to explain yourself
remember you can step back and say i'm
this isn't a requirement
there may be times where i want to
but i don't need to be compelled to
explain
myself i don't have to tell you why i am
or i'm not using
facebook or why i am or i'm not using
instagram or whatever
and the other thing i'm going to tell
you is guess what
most people probably don't actually care
ryan you don't have a facebook account
i'm sure people aren't coming to you and
saying how dare you
no but you know when someone does come
to me and they say how dare you
with whatever boundary i set up which
happens every once in a while sure
you know i try to and i've said this
many times on the podcast before
i try to approach those tense situations
with a de-escalating attitude
and the way that you do that is you
focus on showing that person love you
focus on showing that person some
compassion or empathy or whatever you
want to call it
uh you want to show that person that you
respect them
that's what we want out of every
relationship every human human
interaction we want to feel good we want
to be loved we want to be understood
and we want to be respected so if you
can keep
those things in mind when you're talking
about these boundaries with other people
they're probably they're also probably
going to de-escalate now there are
situations where people
don't de-escalate and they just want to
continue to escalate well that's where
you walk away give it a little time and
then come back to it maybe
now jess social media is the place where
people escalate all the time
and you're so glad we have you to
de-escalate things yeah please be nice
in the youtube comments on monitoring
these
so let's talk about this because people
often escalate much more quickly there
it's like if ryan ryan i loved his
example there people want
love and support but on on social media
it's like well
i'm just going to pull out my
switchblade it's the equivalent of that
right
and and so i mean i guess why do we do
that
what are your thoughts because you see
it so much i think it's
um a precarious situation because
everyone's at the table
every there's somebody at like in mumbai
from the table
there like is a woman who like you know
picks rice in china there's like
somebody in russia at the table
and we have to be thoughtful of
everybody's feelings that we don't even
know what their backgrounds are
that's so hard like if if somebody was
in the room and i know they had a
situation
that i should be sensitive about i would
be aware of it but since everybody's in
the room
we have to be thoughtful of that but
really what i think what it comes down
to is we are a product of our
experiences
and the more experiences we have the
more
broad of people that we become and i
think when you become
an open-minded person and you realize
that everyone's coming
to you with their resources and their
tools and their experiences
you realize there's a reason that they
are the way they are and there may they
may have something
in their past that you don't know about
that like if you had that same
experience you would feel the same way
so i think we really have to recognize
that like things are the way they are
for a reason
and you might not know that reason and
if you did you might even change your
mind
well that's what's great about feedback
or i think in the documentary they
they say criticism specifically um
jaren lanier he's yeah i mean he he
wrote a great book about
what 10 reasons you should quit social
media and we could differentiate it
between criticism and feedback but
sometimes feedback feedback can have
some
criticism in it that isn't so sharp it's
not with the blade but long story short
is
when we get those experiences when
people point things out
it actually helps us present a better
argument yeah yeah what i love what
jessica's saying here because
it sounds like what you're describing is
compassion and
having compassion even for those who are
we call them seagulls right
because there's sean put a link to that
essay about seagulls but
uh they'll put it in show notes but uh
seagulls fly over
whatever you've done they crap on it
they fly away
that's what a that's what a seagull does
and we can even have compassion for them
now we'll still block you
but in fact i think blocking someone is
often the most compassionate thing you
can do
because you're not allowing them to
continue their suffering
in your home right or in in your your
place of communication
it's like someone came into your house
and they're being belligerent
and you're self-harming yes and you're
basically saying
um you're not well you need to leave the
house
you're not welcome in my home it reminds
me i think louis ck was on fallon maybe
and he was talking about
uh the way that people experience social
media and the difference between between
that and real life interactions and if i
say something mean to you
and i look at your face and i see your
micro expressions and i realized that i
was just a jerk
like then that changes things and i
think that because of the fact that we
don't have that
in-person like visceral response to
these negative interactions
the block is the closest thing that we
have to it because when you go to that
page you have this visceral reaction
of like the electronic version of a
frown saying like
you made me feel bad and now you're not
allowed to talk to me anymore and
i think it's a beautiful boundary to
draw i love it one time
one time i was going to block somebody
and i sent josh blocks a picture of
blocks i'm like we're gonna have a block
party today
i think we may have posted the uh
organizing as well planned hoarding
essay that day
oh yeah some people get very mad about
what i always look into some very sort
of innocuous words and then
what i find people get yeah people get
really angry about these exceptions
and and and they think that there aren't
we're not allowing exceptions for
anything and it's and it's like well
there's always no matter what philosophy
you look at like there's going to be an
exception to the rules that
that are laid out i also i'm sorry i
just want to mention that i
also don't block everybody that's a jerk
because sometimes
i think it's i think it's valuable to
make sure that there's a conversation to
be had because if somebody else notices
that they're a jerk
and they're like hey i'm going to point
out to you that you were a jerk right
like
so i think that it's important to you
know leave those conversations be
because it creates a dialogue and that
person needs that dialogue
yeah yes absolutely you know what you
just gave me an idea i would love
to take like the most visceral
conversation that we can find
on the internet and then the skit is
everyone in the same room
talking to each other yeah like
reading reading the comments back and
forth to each other like that
because you would never do that if you
were in the same room with someone well
i would it would
be even better if you hire like
well-known actors to act it out oh yeah
and they're acting out these comments to
each other typos and all
i'll be so good yeah so this would be
really good patent-pending brian i'm
going to send you a copy of the
minimalist rule book you're asking about
boundaries well
one way to define a boundary is to call
them rules right
ryan and i came up with 16 rules for
living with
less it's a free ebook you can get it
the minimalists.com
resources there's also an audiobook
version of that available now as well
ryan and i recorded it we even did a
mini podcast
associated with each of the 16 rules so
you can check out the free ebook version
or the audiobook version the
minimalists.com rulebook for the
audiobook version
and you can download the free ebook
there